[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends welcome to Bible answers
live would you like to hear an amazing
fact doctors are mystified as to why a
55 year old New York man who was blind
for 20 years should suddenly begin
seeing again Kevin Coughlin
who has a hereditary condition called
Liebherr optic neuropathy awoke one day
to discovered his vision was
miraculously returning without any
medical intervention the spontaneous
reversal of this disease that destroyed
his optic nerve cells has never happened
before the only thing Kevin can think of
is that he began to pray daily and eat
more vegetables now he can actually lead
his seeing-eye dog friends you know the
Bible says that God is in the business
of opening blind eyes stay with us we're
going to learn more on this edition of
Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
thats one eight hundred four sixty three
seventy to ninety seven now let's join
our host pastor doug batchelor and our
co-host pastors Jean Ross welcome
listening friends to Bible answers live
and that's pretty much what we do we are
alive and we do our best to answer your
Bible questions for the next Oh roughly
55 minutes you can call in with any
Bible related question or something that
talks about living the Christian life we
don't claim to have all the answers we
have some of them and we've got our
Bibles in front of us it's a free phone
call 800 god says eight hundred four six
three seven two ninety seven lines open
right now good chance if you call right
now
you'll get your question on tonight's
program one more time eight hundred God
says eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven with your Bible questions
I'm Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross
good evening listening friends and pass
it up as we always do let's start the
program with prayer dear father in
heaven we thank you that we can open up
your word and study together this
evening and we want to invite your
presence to be with us be with those who
are listening Lord and lead us into a
clearer understanding of the Bible for
you have said we shall know the truth
and the truth will set us free bless our
time together in Jesus name Amen amen
Oh pastor day that's a remarkable story
I guess it's remarkable in itself that
someone suffering from that condition
would be able to see again but the only
thing he really did was spend some time
in prayer increased his prayer time try
to eat healthfully and miraculously he
began to see yeah he started eating more
vegetables he was trying to get some of
the antioxidants and he had been feeling
sorry for himself for years and he
snapped out and said well I'm gonna
start meditating and praying and all of
a sudden it went from being totally you
know blacked out to kind of cloudy and
then figures and it just kept getting
sharper and sharp
where he goes out now and he doesn't
need anyone he walks his dog and it is
he can see color
so it's just an amazing thing the
doctors are saying the doctors are
calling it a miracle you read the
article online it's pretty amazing but
it didn't surprise me all through the
Bible Hugh and I read stories where God
opened blind eyes this was one of the
miracles that Jesus performed that was
pretty remarkable one instance in
particular in John chapter 9 a man who
had been blind from birth and they say
that if you don't see by the time you're
three or the the part of your brain
where your sight develops even if they
were to give you perfectly good eyes
you'll never learn to see because the
part that understands sight it's past
the time when it can work and jesus
healed a man who had been born blind
that was you know thirty years old and
so it actually foretold the Messiah
would do that it says to open blind eyes
and to bring the prisoners out of prison
and the revelation God says I counsel
you to anoint your eyes with eyesalve i
anoint m''d that you might see so
throughout the New Testament there's
also a symbol where sight represents
spiritual vision and God wants us to
have our spiritual eyes open so we know
what the truth is we know where we're
going sometimes you try to share or the
person what the truth is and they might
harden their hearts and close their eyes
and Jesus referred to those people as
spiritually blind and he talked about
the false religious leaders as blind the
guides you can read and Luke 639 he said
can the blind lead the blind will they
not both fall in the ditch and there are
a lot of people out there that claim to
know the Lord they claim to be spiritual
and they are just spiritually blind a
lot of counterfeit and we have a free
offer that we're gonna make available
that will help people know how do you
receive your spiritual sight how do you
avoid spiritual blindness a book is
entitled hidden eyes and closed ears
written by Joe cruise and this is a free
offer for today if you just give us a
call and after the book called hidden
eyes and closed is
be happy to send that to anybody who
calls and asks the number to call our
resource phone line is 808 three five
six seven four seven that number again
is 808 three five six seven four seven
and you can answer the book called
hidden eyes and closed ears we'll be
happy to send it to you for free if
you're outside of North America
you can read the book for free online
just go to the amazing facts website
just amazing facts dot o-r-g
type in a little blind their search
engine it says hidden eyes and closed
eyes hidden years sorry
hidden eyes and closed ears and you can
read the book for free right there
online if you have a Bible question I've
online here to the studio is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven that's eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven pass it on
I think we're ready to go to our first
caller Lee we've got let's see Sean
listening from actually no it's bill
listening in Lafayette Louisiana bill
welcome to the program yeah thank you
very much
our pastor Doug you please help me try
to understand the evolution of
prehistoric man how they know to see the
fossils it started to look like they
were becoming very human light and I
mean there's proof through the faucet
you can't deny that so what so I don't
know what Mike what Mike thinking is
that God let evolution continued and all
of a sudden says well I'm gonna start
making I'm gonna make man a my own image
and likeness I cut off me yeah yeah you
want me to jump on jump in here for a
second hi William
um I categorically respectfully disagree
there are hundreds of thousands if not
millions of fossils of Homo sapiens they
can't find any fossils of what you would
call the missing link are people that
are half-man half-god they looked all
over Africa and they found fragments of
skulls of what most people believe
really gorillas but the the avid
evolutionists say this is the missing
link if there really was an age of
millions of years where they were these
transitions of half-man half-ape you'd
have millions of fossils there
millions of fossils of gorillas and
chimpanzees millions of father's fossils
and Homo sapiens but they can't find but
a couple of fragments of what they're
trying to say are the missing links and
so there really is no evidence that
there was this half man you know they
found some in a cave in France they
found some bones that they're calling
the Ender fall but there are few bones
and some of argued these are just humans
with arthritis and a number of them that
they said that we found Java man they
later found out was that based on that
was plate down man the tooth of an
extinct Pig and so there's just who
wasn't the guy who wrote Sherlock Holmes
he pulled the big hoax no I don't know
that was Plitt down man they had all
these different and it was a hoax
something that he had taken a half
orangutan skull and half of the human
jaw bone and he put them together and
hid it where he knew a friend was
digging and they said ah we found the
missing link and later it was the scare
it was a hoax Arthur Conan Doyle that's
his name how old do you think how long
ago was AB was Edmund and Adam and Eve
well if you add up the ages in the Bible
if you believe the Bible and you add up
the ages it counts back about 6,000
years to the time of Adam it tells you
Adam lived 930 years and it tells you
how long Seth lived in eNOS and all the
way up through Abraham and we can fairly
accurately date Abraham's birth at about
2004 BC and there's a really good
history because you know Abraham he
lived during there's Egyptian kings that
we know when they lived and you can kind
of cross compare between Abraham and
Moses and the Joseph and the different
Egyptian kings so and it's interesting
no matter where you go in the world
there are no trees that are older than
6,000 years there's no written history
it's over 4,000 years all of a sudden
man appears on the scene and he's
building pyramids with incredible math
and these amazing cities and to just say
that you know a few generations before
he was dragging his knuckles and
suddenly understands calculus
I'm sorry I just don't believe that well
how old do you think the earth is then
well that's a good question
the I think that the the actual material
that God began creating some believe
that you know that the raw mass may have
been here for a while because in Genesis
it says God saw the earth was void and
chaos and he began to form and create it
and that's you know six days of creation
roughly 6,000 years ago I know if you
listen to where the science I mean it's
it's 6,000 compare the four billion oh
that's a big jump yeah well how do you
get the number four billion think about
that well the carbon data and all the
other I mean well but how do they give
you a carbon go to them you go to the
mountains you look all these canyons all
these old rocks and you say my gosh this
cannot be 6,000 years old this has got
to go away well you know the Bible says
there was a pretty woman a pretty
massive flood and the whole earth went
through terrible you know dramatic
shifts about 4,500 years ago and that
the whole surface of the earth was
changed by that you know I could I could
take a whole hour right now and talk
about evolution or asking some questions
you know we do have a free offer we'll
send you a book I think you'll enjoy
it's called when evolution flunked the
science test mm-hmm yeah I didn't read
that you know there's also some I've got
a sermon that I did online if you don't
mind looking at it it's free just type
in evolution and evolution and logic and
let me know what you think of that
william and we do appreciate your call
next calling is katherine listening from
georgia katherine welcome to the program
hi pastors thank you so much for taking
my call i deeply appreciate your
ministry my question lies within Matthew
24 it's kind of multifaceted I'll make
it quick
these states that pray that your flight
be not in winter if that's literal of
course if it's not winter for me it's
going to be a winter person
one do I pray selfishly then it not be
winter for me and does that indicate the
time the Lent that the tribulation will
be for a season the second part is how
do I plan for that I know that I could
die before the tribulation however I'm a
widow so I have no means I was widowed
at a young age and I've no means to go
to the country and to plan so do I buy
things gradually as I can now and store
them in my home or do I just wait
patiently upon the Lord and see how he
provides well trust the Lord Catherine
first of all you're asking a question
it's in Matthew chapter 24 Oh pray that
here that's verse 20 I believe yeah
pray your flight be not in the winter
neither on the Sabbath Jesus was just
there's two things Jesus is saying first
of all in Matthew 24 he's talking about
the destruction of Jerusalem and the end
of the world he was telling the
disciples pray that your flight when you
have to flee from Jerusalem is not in
the winter there'd be no food in the
fields or on the Sabbath for obvious
reasons it was a holy day of worship and
rest and and you know it turns out that
when the Romans surrounded the city and
an opportunity came for the Christians
to escape from Jerusalem because the
Romans temporarily withdrew that it was
not on a Sabbath so they were praying
regarding the destruction of Jerusalem
that they wouldn't have to flee in the
winter now that also applies us in the
last days we should pray that you know
whenever the day comes if we have to run
for our lives that it will not be in a
season that's difficult I don't know
you'd be thinking well but if it's not
winter in the northern hemisphere it's
winter somewhere but you know there's
quite frankly there's a lot more people
that would be hurt in the northern
hemisphere by winter than in the
southern hemisphere so as far as just
the population of the world and how it's
dispersed I wouldn't worry Catherine
about not having enough money to buy
land and store away food
do you just continue to trust God and be
faithful to be a witness where you are
say Lord if you open the doors and you
want me to do this show me
providentially and he will but don't
worry about it
right thank you very much appreciate
your ministry absolutely and we have a
book that I think you'll enjoy that
talks about prayer and it's called teach
us to pray
I'm gonna call for that is 808 three
five six seven four seven you can answer
the book called teach us to pray we'll
be happy to send that to you Catherine
or anybody who calls and asks my next
call is a Nancy listening in Michigan
Nancy welcome to the program thank you
for taking my car I love you program
well thank you for calling as soon as
you're welcome my question is in Luke 24
27 and beginning with the mothers and
all the prophets he explained to them
what was said all the scriptures
concerning himself what is his name
well when Jesus rose from the dead he's
walking from Jerusalem down towards the
town called Emmaus and there's two
disciples there and they're all
discouraged as Jesus died and he said
didn't you know that the Scriptures said
all the way from Moses to Malachi
because of course when Jesus was living
they had no New Testament yet that the
Messiah would suffer and rise and he
began to take them through the
prophecies prophecies like Micah and
prophecies in Zechariah and prophecies
in Isaiah and David in the Psalms that
all foretold his sufferings and his
resurrection and their hearts began to
warm and get encouraged as they realized
oh you mean Jesus didn't fail but this
was all I'm supposed to happen and that
he did rise you know the women said they
saw him come back to life or they saw an
angel that said he's alive and they
thought well maybe the women aren't
crazy maybe they really did see this
vision and they were greatly encouraged
and later they realized they're talking
to Jesus they didn't even know it at
first
he kind of had veiled their vision so
but that's one of my favorite verses you
just quoted because I believe the Bible
all the way from Genesis to Revelation
is about Jesus not just the New
Testament but all through the Old
Testament I see sightings of Christ
I see yeah Jesus is in the story of the
exodus and Jesus is in the story of Ruth
and Gideon and Samson and and I just see
Jesus all through the Bible but matter
of fact I've got a book I wrote that is
called shadows of light seeing Christ
and all the Bible you can look online at
Amazon or something and you'll find that
called shadows of light it's a it's a
bigger premium book we can't just give
away but that was my favorite subject so
I wrote a larger book on it but what do
we have we can give we're looking for a
book dealing with resource Thoreau will
send you a copy the prayer book teach us
to pray you'll enjoy your head yeah the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
ask for the book called teach us to pray
we'll be able to send that to you Nancy
or anybody who picks up the phone and
calls our phone line here to the studio
is eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven that's 800 God says four
six three seven two nine seven the next
call is Shawn listening from Ironwood
Michigan Shawn welcome to the program
thank you I appreciate you taking my
call this evening well thank you I have
a question related to the timing of the
crucifixion I really enjoy spending time
each day reflecting on the life of Jesus
and I've read the Gospels many times but
I've never quite figured out the timing
with how mark 1525 says now was the
third hour and they crucified him I've
always thought that's 9 a.m. but then
I've tried to understand what time John
19:14
comes in where it says now was the
preparation day of the Passover and
about the sixth hour and he said to the
Jews behold your king that's Pilate
saying behold your king so and I wasn't
sure if that what verse were you in John
16 you said John 19 verse 40 oh I'm
sorry mm-hmm and so I know that John
earlier in John 4 verse 6 speaks about
Jesus meeting the woman at the well and
that was the sixth hour and that's noon
but if John 19:14 is noon
why is pilot saying behold your king
when he has already been hanging on the
cross for three hours so yeah that is a
good question I mean that is yeah that
is a good question
most of the Gospels are in harmony that
Jesus probably because see there they
tried him at night then early in the
morning it says they brought him to
Pilate and the other Gospels say he was
crucified at what we would call third
hour of the day which would be nine
o'clock the sky grew dark at noon and he
died at about 3:00 he was six hours on
the cross alive probably one hour dead
as they got permission to take his body
down which is interesting means he was
on the cross for seven hours Oh
six hours alive and suffering one hour
resting it's kind of interesting that
way but what John says is an anomaly I
don't know if pastor Ross has an answer
for that but you know probably ought to
dig into one of the commentaries and
find out why does it look like there's a
discrepancy why would pilots say that at
the 6:00 hour if Jesus had already been
condemned according to the other Gospels
and crucified by then I think first of
all we just need to recognize that he
says about so I mean we're not specific
they want keeping a stopwatch there was
a lot happening roughly during that time
period and Johnny's riding near the end
of the 1st the close of the first
century primarily he's writing to the
Gentile believers and here he gives a a
form of time that was more familiar to
the Gentiles then what you'd read in
some of the other Gospels elsewhere he
would reckon the hours of the day from
sunrise rather than from midnight so
there's a difference audience that's
been addressed here and you got the
Hebrew time and you've got more of the
Greek time so that does come into play
as well okay good question makes me look
it up does that does that mean then that
John is actually saying that 6 a.m.
because I tried to search this online
and kind of get an idea and I was
thinking maybe John saying that's like 6
a.m. that might fit I don't know there's
a sixth hour that you think is that does
that fit with 3 s's according to Roman
time it's about 6 and
morning okay okay because that would to
me that would make the most sense
they're going through the preliminaries
anything behold your king trying to
awaken sympathy for Jesus but doesn't
work and then yeah yeah so the
difference is whether they be using
Hebrew time were they using the Roman
time and most people feel that John here
is referencing the Roman time which
would put at six o'clock and then of
course the crucifixion at 9:00 okay so
six a.m. and and then three hours later
the mark 15 25 30 hours then he is
crucified at 90 oh wait
that's exciting okay you know I've while
you were talking with Pastor Ross I
looked up some of the commentaries and
they actually are saying there are some
other manuscripts of the Gospel of John
where it also says it is the ninth nine
o'clock or what we would call the third
hour anyway so yeah it is an interesting
verse it might have been John was using
Roman time and the other Gospel writers
were using the Hebrew time they divided
the day in like four sections good
question I got to dig into that thank
you very much appreciate your call
all right mixed kohli is let's see we've
got Robert listening from New Jersey
Robert welcome to the program thank you
Pastor Doug for taking the phone call
yeah so my question tonight is does
purgatory exist well for our listening
france purgatory is related to the word
to purge is a Catholic teaching that
basically says that you know because
we're all so imperfect and heaven is
pure in God as pure that if we die even
if you die saved to get ready for heaven
you may have to go through some purging
where you'll suffer in some fires to
kind of get out the final dross of sin
this isn't taught anywhere in the Bible
so the idea that you know a person could
be suffering in sort of a preliminary
hell or temporary hell until they get
prayed out that came through the dark
ages it was a teaching that is a
leftover of Greek mythology where you've
got Hades and they found that it was
financially very beneficial for the
priests
to be able to say well so-and-so wasn't
quite good enough to go right to heaven
they're in purgatory but if you make an
offering we will pray and get him out of
purgatory now if you really believe
you've got a loved one that is burning
in flame and through your prayers and
your offerings you can somehow shorten
that period you can see how the church
leaders were able to manipulate people
and get extravagant amounts of money
through fear right but okay let me see
I'm trying to remember there's one of
the church teachings that was a Pope
Benedict renounce was at limbo or
purgatory I think maybe it was limbo
they said they really is no limbo and
they finally abandoned that but
purgatory is very much still part of the
yeah with teaching yeah but it's you
don't find the word of the teaching
anywhere in the Bible that you know a
person can be burned temporarily and
then go to heaven either Jesus died for
sins or not but why does the Catholic
Church preach that there's verses in the
Bible that point to purgatory well it'd
be convenient but what are those verses
do you have any well I mean maybe
Ezekiel 33 11 and the souls that are
were martyred that wait for revenge are
they waiting in purgatory for God to
avenge their death I'm going there right
now you're talking about in the book of
Revelation we talks about the souls
under the altar yes the souls under the
altar typing his revelation 6:9 yeah
Ezekiel 33 11 says I have no pleasure in
the death of the wicked but the wicked
turn from his way and live it doesn't
say anything about purgatory the souls
under the altar in Revelation is pretty
clearly a symbol because you know
they're waking up it doesn't say they're
suffering it just says they're crying
how long until we're avenged and God
says rest a little longer so they go
back to sleep yeah you know if you look
at that that of course is part of the
fifth seal there's a series of seals
that you have in the book of Revelation
they represent different time periods
the fifth seal spans the time period of
severe persecution
I came upon many Bible believing
Christians during the Dark Ages and in
symbolic terms you have souls crying out
saying how long until this persecution
is to end Revelation is a very symbolic
book and there's a lot of imagery here
just like you have Abel's blood crying
out from the ground so you have those
who lay down their life the question
he's asked how long until they are
avenged so again that's not referencing
purgatory by any means it's a symbolic
description of a time period yeah you
know we've got a free offer we'll be
happy to share with you Robert it's
called are the dead really dead I've
also got the offer is the devil in
charge of Hell that would talk a little
bit about some of these things yeah and
what you send that you read that you'll
see everything the Bible says in this
subject and I think it'll be pretty
clear to you that people don't die and
go to purgatory you can read 1st
Thessalonians chapter 4 when the Lord
descends then the dead in Christ rise
are caught up they meet the Lord in the
air out there forever with the Lord they
go from their graves to the presence of
the Lord they don't go through a waiting
area that where they're burning that's
was not taught in the Bible what what
happens to the souls before Jesus was
walked on earth that was saved that had
passed on that died was Hades hell split
into two groups where the saves were not
tortured and it was a part of Hell where
the on States were tortured until Jesus
came died and he was God does not have
one kind of hell for people in the Old
Testament and one kind of hell for
people in the New Testament please read
those studies we got to take a break
here please read those studies I think
you're gonna find that a blessing
friends if you're standing by we're
gonna get your call don't give up and we
do our lines open if someone wants to
join the program in the second half it's
800 God says 800 for six three seven two
nine seven anyway don't go away we're
gonna just get a drink of water and come
back and do more Bible questions
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept
hello this is Joe Cruz and the amazing
facts broadcast facts which affect you
each radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a Bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every walk of life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of television to its growing outreach
efforts offering soul-winning
evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world
in 1994 pastor Doug Batchelor assumed
leadership of the ministry adding the
Bible answers live call-in radio program
and new ministry TV programs began
airing on multiple networks around the
world for 50 years the driving vision of
amazing facts has been the bold
proclamation of the everlasting gospel
and with a team of evangelists circling
the globe and thousands of men and women
being trained through the amazing facts
center of evangelism program Affco the
ministry is helping God's church see a
rich harvest of souls amazing facts
God's message our mission
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 72 97 I am
Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross
pastor Doug before we go to the phone
lines we've got an exciting event that's
coming up in just a few weeks now of
ember the 3rd through the 11th and it's
called foundations of faith that's right
less than a month we're gonna be
traveling to Maryland and from there
we're going to be uplinking around the
world via satellite it will be on the
Hope channel which you can see on
DirecTV anyone with DirecTV can tune in
to this program
it'll also be on glory star amazing
facts TV 3abn which is on networks
around the country plus of course all of
the streaming
Facebook and other social media sites
foundations of faith you know we're
right gonna be on the cusp of the
anniversary of the Reformation 500 year
anniversary and we're gonna be we don't
have time for 95 theses but we're gonna
do 9 we're gonna talk about some of the
pillars of Christianity that have been
neglected
we need another Reformation to
continue foundations of faith you want
more information how you can tune in
it's real easy foundations of faith dot
info just go ww foundations of faith dot
info and you'll find the information
there and be praying as we prepare for
these presentations all right back to
the phone lines we've got some New York
Phil welcome to the program Phil you're
on the air very much yes thank you very
much I wanted just to make a quick
comment about the gentleman who spoke
about purgatory if I may before I ask my
question
I wonder where years ago many years ago
I asked a Catholic priest I said you
guys just made an individual a saint
according to the manmade practice of
canonization and beatification I said
how do you know that that particular
individual that you say now is a saint
is out of purgatory and he pretty much
choked on his food I think there's no
answer it's just a man-made scam to keep
people paying for them to do the Holy
Sacrifice of the mass and move a loved
one up the ladder which is totally cured
to what Christ told the thief on the
cross this day you shall be with me in
paradise
you know there is no condemnation for
those who are in Christ Jesus that's
right
my question the reason why I called
those of us who are Christian we're
exposed to television and we
occasionally I come across this medium
show that the person who communicates
with the dead I know what Deuteronomy
says that it's an abomination to the
Lord but here's my question I see that
some people are coming closer to the
Lord those that had no faith are now
realizing there is something there let
me explore this Jesus let me explore
Christ
it's alleviating guilt in many scenarios
it's alleviating worry and it's
enhancing faith for some for some and
I'm just wondering where's the
abomination part if it's drawing people
to a reality that there is more than
just this world all right first of all
even if we don't understand why if God
says do not do it
do not consult them then we ought to see
alright Lord we won't because there may
be all kinds of feelings that are a
positive or encouraging that happened
was something wrong I've you know heard
of men that start to have an affair with
her secretary and they say but we're
having such a wonderful time together
and we love each other and we praying
together so it must be ok you know
that's what makes deception so dangerous
is the devil will try to mix something
that seems good with something that's
dangerous it's diabolical the Bible
tells us we should not be consulting a
medium or someone that has familiar
spirits because they're talking to
devils and see Devils can impersonate
dead people and they can say all kinds
of encouraging some you know wonderful
things that will get other people
involved in these dark arts but the
Bible says the living know they'll die
but the dead don't know anything the
dead do not communicate with the living
the Bible tells us that not until we get
to heaven are we gonna see our loved
ones you nothing in the Bible encourages
us to talk to the dead I think you got
Isaiah and what is it 8:20 it said
according to the law and the testimony
if they don't speak according to this
word there's no light in them don't go
to Wizards that peep and mutter in the
dark why would the living consult the
dead so and you can look at what
happened to King Saul went to a medium
just before his death and as a result of
that he died the next day you know we've
all seen or at least the Bible's filled
with stories and I know some of us have
passed today you've also seen it that
the devil is alive and well and there
are such things as demon possession
we've seen in Africa we've seen in
different mission fields is he living in
North America it's a dangerous thing for
somebody to open themselves up or expose
themselves to these evil forces that
might masquerade is dead loved ones the
Bible is pretty clear the dead don't
know anything so the devil is gonna do
everything you can to deceive and I
think that's one of the reasons why God
is so adamant that believers should not
consult mediums
yeah and no I'm not denying
that there could be the appearance that
something wonderful has happened and
that's what would bring other people in
and get them attracted that's why that's
why Jesus said in the last days the
deceptions would be so cunning that if
it were possible even the very elect
would be deceived and so I would I'd
encourage you Phil to stay far and away
from those things you know we do have a
study guide called
all the dead really dead and I think
that'll help answer some of these
questions we'll be happy to send this to
anybody who calls and asks the number is
883 five six seven four seven again
that's 808 three five six seven four
seven you can ask the study guide called
are the dead really dead or could he
send it to you the great Bible study
dealing with the subject of what happens
when a person dies you know and
especially now as we're on the verge of
Halloween you a lot of people are
wondering about these things and we have
another book that we could also send
free or you can read it online it's
called spirits of the Dead
spirits of the Dead do they speak in
here spirits of the Dead do they speak
in here by Joe Cruz it's a classic you
want a free copy we'll send you one if
you want to read it online simply go to
amazing facts dot-com or.org
and go to our free library you'll see it
there you know I'm glad you mention that
pass today you got me thinking about
something it's not always that we can
promote this website but this is a good
time of year for us to do just that we
have a website called ghost truth
dot-com just simply ghost truth calm a
lot of great information there that'll
help educate people on what the Bible
teaches on the subject of what happens
when a person dies absolutely now take a
look at that neil ghost truths calm I
think he'll enjoy that the next qualies
Alex and he's listening in Michigan Alex
welcome to the program hi Alex and how
can we help you tonight my question for
you is about bitterness okay I'm going
to I'm sorry for the crude way of trying
to get my question across but let's say
that to Christian individuals were very
bitter at each other
and they passed away without this
bitterness being settled this matter of
bitterness how how can two people
possibly relate to each other when
they're and when they're in heaven if
they're extremely bitter at each other
before they die I mean I know our minds
are going to be changed and you know
things are going to be we're going to
look at things differently but I'm just
the other day just kind of went across
my mind I mean as far as how are we
going to totally forget you know some of
the stuff that's happened down here I
mean I'm not going to walk around hating
somebody no but you know there are
grievances that we have with each other
even this Christian well you know first
of all there needs to be forgiveness you
can look in the Bible Paul was
responsible for stoning Stephen now
they're gonna meet in heaven someday and
one killed the other but you know what
Paul was converted and Stephen he prayed
for the forgiveness of those that were
stoning him right at his execution
what's even more concerning to me is two
people that are professed Christians
that will not release her resolve
bitterness and anger because you know
what Jesus said he tells us that unless
you forgive your brother their
trespasses your father in heaven will
not forgive you your trespasses now
that's in the Lord's Prayer and it's
also in Matthew 18 so boy a person who
will not forgive someone else that's
that's very dangerous ground that
they're living on if now it doesn't mean
like if someone's taking advantage of
you and you let's say you've got a
brother or sister in the Lord and you
have a bad experience they take
advantage of you well you can forgive
them you just don't have to do business
with them or you don't have to interact
with them anymore but you can forgive
them and just let it go for your own
sake and just pray that God will give
you peace about it that doesn't mean you
have to engage them anymore he doesn't
mean you have to do business with him
but when you a person harbors a nerd
nurtures this bitterness and then
go to their graves that way what's not
the Holy Spirit's not help them
experience conversion you've got to let
let those things go and forgive so hey I
appreciate that question and in heaven
of course no one's gonna be angry and
bitter even Paul and who is it Paul and
Barnabas had a big blowout argument over
mark mm-hmm but they later reconciled
you know you can see the Bible apostles
fought over who was the greatest but I
and they prayed together and got over it
it's when Christians supposed Christians
can't let it go and can't get along
that's not good
all right next caller thank you very
much appreciate that call all right
we've got James listening from New York
James welcome to the program how you
doing tonight
doing good how are you yeah I'm fine
okay my question tonight is this a
friend of my brother's have confessed
Jesus the Lord and Savior you know more
than once you know was a regular church
at Cindy but yet last Thursday for
whatever reason unbeknownst to family
and friends he committed suicide
hmm so my question is a person who
confessed Jesus and believed in Jesus
and all of that when they allow you know
the weight of the world to overcome them
to the point that they no longer want to
live in it what happens with that person
as for them so you know their spirit or
whatever salvation yeah well yeah that
is a good question it's probably one of
the toughest questions because in most
cases when a person takes their life not
in every case they've reached a point of
hopelessness they've lost faith and
Bible says without faith it's impossible
to please God and then the last act of
their life is one of self murder which
of course we're not supposed to murder
anybody including ourselves our lives
are a gift from God we are not our own
we belong to God so we have no right to
kill anybody when no right to kill
ourselves
but you know we need to stop short of
saying a person who commits suicide that
they're all lost because we don't know
what's going on in a person's life we
don't know the burdens they're bearing
we don't know the pain they're going
through we don't know if there's some
chemical or mental unbalance that it's a
medical condition I mean so you got to
be very careful not to judge you do have
a couple cases in the Bible where you
have Samson who you know the last act of
his life he's filled with the Spirit of
God and he frankly he prays for the
Spirit of God so he can push down the
building and he knows that he's gonna
die because his last words are let me
die with the Philistines and they were
maybe getting ready to kill him also at
that event we don't know but you could
classify him as a suicide but he really
sacrificed his life to defeat God's
enemies so yeah the the suicides in the
Bible people like Saul who fell on his
sword and Judas who hung himself those
stories don't end well and so if anyone
out there is thinking of suicide and
you're thinking that it's gonna somehow
assure you into a better existence if
you're a believer suicide may take away
all of your options and permanently lock
you into a very bad situation so please
don't think of suicide as a way out now
I don't know that may have sounded a
little bit as a like a convoluted answer
James I don't know if that helped I mean
I could totally
I told me can understand how you
explained I told you I understand it at
a first amaz'd a way is hopeless no life
is worth living no more so yeah I kind
of I can understand it all right you
know and if you want more on that
subject yeah absolutely I think I've got
an article I do online that specifically
deals with the subject of suicide and
you can just look up Doug Batchelor
comments on suicide and I think you'll
find that thank you James for your call
and I think we do still have one or two
lines open and you could probably get in
tonight's program if you take a crack at
it the number to call if you'd like to
talk to us here at the studio this
evening is 804 six three seven two nine
seven that's 804 63 72 97 annex call
he's Mary and she is in Detroit
Mary welcome to the program thank you so
much for taking my car you pastors my
call is somewhat similar to that last
caller I haven't had a nephew and he 20
years old which we will be burying him
on tomorrow and we're not sure if
possible he could have taken his life
I'm not sure if my question really was
if God you know how can i you know need
something encouraging to say to the
family
they're not believers at all and
sometimes when when when things like
that when tragedy or something happened
they don't they're not really receptive
to hear about God because they see if
they think if there's a God why would he
let this happen yeah what could I say to
them tomorrow that means they're hurting
really baby oh I know you know well we
lost the son that was 23 a few years ago
and so I can I can relate a little bit
it's just heartbreaking you know all the
things that people said to me one thing
stuck with me of course I'm a believer
so but another friend who had actually
lost a son years earlier he said what
happens in you now is more important
than what has happened to you and you
know I really thought about that and God
can even work something good out of
heartache Paul talks about we go through
tough experiences so that we can comfort
others with the comfort wherewith we are
comforted now you know God comforted our
family when we lost his son years ago
and now that comfort he gave us we are
able to share with others that go
through serious trials and so yeah you
might just tell them you you don't
understand now you have been hit by a
tsunami the waves are going to get
smaller and they'll be further apart
just remember that tell them you know
they've been hit by a wave a tidal wave
it will get better you're gonna continue
to have waves of grief but the waves
will start getting smaller and they're
going to be further apart and so they
just need to get through it and they'll
start to realize that it's gonna be
difficult and it takes a long time you
never forget
but it gets where you can live again and
you can even laugh again and it's just
you know you've heard the old adage time
heals yeah just tell them hang on hang
on they know I'm saying you need to tell
them hang on you're going through a
storm that just got to hang onto the
boat yeah I was thinking I was trying to
think of a scripture that I could oh
well I wasn't sure to give you a
scripture not because yeah I thought you
said they might recoil at something
religious yeah I don't know I thought of
it well you know Tommy 23 when I go
through the valley of the shadow of
death thou art with me you got any
pastor Ross God is with them yeah they
may sense that you know I would also
tell them God lost the son he knows just
how they feel oh yeah you know I did
when I was at the cemetery you know
preparing you know when they were making
those finalisation that the cemetery I
didn't get a chance to you know just
kind of pray because I have really been
carrying their burden so heavy yeah it's
heartbreaking you know because they
didn't and and reason why I caught I'm
caught tonight - okay I heard your
program today and you made weapons up
you're 23 year old son Micah yes yeah
probably watch I don't mention it often
so you're probably watching a program
from a few years ago cuz that was that's
been now today's broadcast today yeah oh
my goodness this is this is something
that I need
to talk to to help for tomorrow well
good to hopefully that yeah tell them
that say you know the Lord he lost the
son he knows how they feel and that
might encourage him we're gonna try and
squeeze in a couple more callers and we
will also remember to pray for that
family Mary that is a very very
difficult experience
let's call ease Wayne listening from New
Jersey Wayne welcome to the program in
Carnation well you know reincarnation
the idea that you you die and you come
back again there's only one
reincarnation and that's called the
resurrection that's when we are raised
up either among the saved or among the
lost the wicked are raised at the end of
the 1,000 years the righteous are raised
when the Lord comes down at the second
coming and but the idea that you're
gonna die again come back is another
person or another creature that's not
taught anywhere in the Bible why you
know the devil would love for people to
believe that because they think well I'm
not gonna try and take this life
seriously if I don't get it right this
life I'll get another chance no this is
the only life where we choose our
eternal destiny and that's why you've
got one life to live and where's that
verse pastor Ross's at Hebrews where it
says it's appointed unto man once to die
after that the judgment
yeah so hopefully that'll help a little
bit and appreciate your question thank
you very much my is that Miley yeah
thank you
let's even get a couple more insurance
heroes Kevin listening in California
Kevin welcome to the program
hi papa yeah I have a question are you
know okay for believer to marry a
non-believer you know I know there you
know whether he's gonna press you after
the marriage with the devil try every
possibility to break up your marriage
because you're kind of unequally yoked
together you know I would like to listen
to your opinion
yeah well the Bible's pretty clear that
a believer should not marry someone that
doesn't have the same faith
because it causes all kinds of problems
in the marriage and you just wait until
kids come along and one parent is
teaching them one worldview one parent
says you know you're supposed to go to
church and the other parent says no
you're supposed to be a Buddhist or
they're an atheists or an animist sir
it's just terrible strife that cause you
want to there's already enough problems
in marriage when two people get married
there's gonna be enough problems you
don't need to compound them by marrying
someone with a whole different worldview
Jesus said can two walk together unless
they're agreed if you're walking in
different directions and you're married
to someone it's like having a two-headed
turtle you don't know which way to turn
so yeah the Bible of course says do not
be unequally yoked together is that what
first Corinthians chapter 7 pastor
awesome trying to remember I should know
these things but I'm a little dyslexic
with numbers and does that help a little
bit Kevin yeah you trying to convert you
are supposed to become a believer you
know well if you're if you're already
married to someone that doesn't believe
then you would want to be a good witness
you can't hit him over the head with it
you're just gonna have problems but it
says in 2nd Peter that an unbelieving
husband can be converted by the behavior
of his believing wife the verse
referring to there is 2nd Corinthians
chapter 6 verse 14 do not be unequally
yoked together with unbelievers yeah and
you don't get yoked any tighter than
marriage that's so alright hey thank you
very much appreciate that Kevin let's
see if we can take another call before
we run out of time we've got Edie
listening in Michigan and welcome to the
program hi how are you doing well thanks
for calling hey I've heard things about
well I know that Jesus loved all of his
disciples but I've always kind of
questioned why John says it describes
himself as the one that Jesus loved well
I I think that there are some people
that it appears that Jesus has a special
love for that God loves everybody but
the the Tenderheart that john had and he
was probably one of the youngest of the
apostles he was a younger brother of
James he became very close to Jesus it's
as you know he literally it says he
leaned on his breast of the Last Supper
they curse they sat in a reclining
eastern tradition when they were eating
back then and you know Jesus sort of
kind of adopted John and mentored him in
a very personal way and John always
thought of himself what a privilege that
Jesus loved me he was always overwhelmed
with a love of Christ for him the Bible
tells us Daniel is referred to by heaven
as greatly beloved it doesn't say that
about shadrach me check or Abednego but
Daniel it says the angel says God says
that you're greatly loved because of his
devotion and he who is forgiven much
loves much
and God has special love for pele people
like Daniel and John and Mary Magdalene
and it seems to be indicated in the
Bible but hey appreciate that pastor
else can we squeeze in one more question
yes two minutes let's see what we get
Philip calling from the Bahamas Philip
we have just a few moments oh yes okay
I'll be quick thanks for taking my call
my question has to do with god the
father on his throne I know that in the
Old Testament many the times when we
read about God appearing to humans
it actually was God the Son and we know
that God is also omnipresent so my
question is is there any actual reason
for God the Father to physically ever
leave his throne when he wants to
manifest himself physically he just does
it through God the Son already wants to
manifest themselves spiritually he does
it through God the spirit is it the case
is it necessary yeah well I'm sorry I'm
jumping in so we can try and touch on
your answer is it necessary well no God
doesn't have to go anywhere if he
doesn't want to is God handcuffed in his
throne no you know he's free to go I
think God the Father was at the delivery
of the Ten Commandments you can read in
Daniel chapter 7 it talks
the son of man coming to the father who
appears to be on his throne but I think
God the father can you know he can go
anywhere he wants through his infinite
creation and appear he's often seen on
his throne and that's a picture of his
majesty
you've got a picture of that there in
Isaiah chapter 6 sorry we kind of rushed
your question fill up in if we didn't
get to some of the others are just
called and hopefully you'll give us a
chance again next week a listening
friends don't forget to tune in to the
foundations of faith program that's
coming in Maryland beginning November 3
through the 11th and you'll see that on
Hope Channel 3abn amazing facts TV type
and foundations of faith info and don't
forget this is entirely supported by you
for you you can go to amazing facts dot
o R G and you can click and make a
little donation keep us on the air
god bless thank you for listening to
today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
amazing facts through your faithful
support has had a major impact on some
of the largest non-christian locations
in the world beyond the Great Wall the
printing and translation of our books
and video materials are in constant
motion southeast Ohio faith oxygen Tian
Shan Java China - the amazing facts
Chinese language website is now one of
our most visited websites we also
translated thousands of pieces of
literature for these nations what
started out as hundreds of followers is
now in the hundreds of thousands the
impact of your funds invested in sharing
the everlasting gospel in these foreign
lands will be felt for years to come
you know every week we hear the most
incredible stories from all over the
globe of lives that are being changed
and hearts that are being transformed by
the power of the word and none of it
could happen without your teamwork with
this ministry god bless you I really
wanted to start a new devotional habit
but life got in the way next thing I
know we're a month into the new year and
I'm like what's the point of starting
then I saw 365 amazing answers to big
Bible questions each day is a single
study so you can start anywhere on any
day and not miss
they're crisp clear and enlightening get
yours today
by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]